[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse webber
and welcome to prime crime tonight this
is where we do a deeper dive into the
most high profile
and memorable true crime cases tonight
one of the biggest stories
of the last 20 years
december 24 2002 modesto california
ron gransky calls 9-1-1 to report that
his step-daughter
has disappeared
her name is lacey peterson the case of
this
missing woman took the nation by storm
with a massive
search expanding to southern california
family and friends of lacey would plead
for her safe return
whoever has her please please please let
her go bring her back we love her so
much
we want her back please
but the focus and suspicions would soon
turn to lacy's husband
scott peterson scott sat down with
police and explained the morning's
events
we were watching her favorite show
martha stewart
watch a little bit of that he said when
he returned home from a fishing trip at
berkeley marina
his pregnant wife was gone authorities
would conduct a search
of the peterson home however the public
and especially those closest to lacey
questioned scott's seemingly casual and
strange behavior and felt
he might be holding back did you murder
your wife
no no i just thought and
i had absolutely nothing to do with her
disappearance
about a month after lacey's
disappearance a woman named
amber frye comes forward and says she
unknowingly was having an affair with
scott
little did he know that fry had been
working with police
and recording their phone calls
on april 14 2003 the bodies of lacey
peterson
and her unborn son connor were found
washed up ashore in richmond california
four days later fearing he may flee the
country police arrest scott peterson
near the mexican border he's sporting
newly dyed hair
a beard carrying ten thousand dollars in
cash and a passport
peterson would ultimately be charged
with two counts of murder
the trial of scott peterson began on
june 1st 2004
lasting five months and with over 170
witnesses taking the stand
the trial was a media frenzy that's
still talked about to this day
in terms of just the trial itself it was
an absolute
circus prosecutors allege that peterson
killed lacey
on or around christmas eve transported
her body in his boat
and tossed her into the san francisco
bay the bodies are
found right in the bay where he
was fishing that day the state though
couldn't identify
how or where lacey was killed and they
didn't even have a murder weapon
the jury though convicted peterson of
murdering lacey and connor and he would
be sentenced to death
yet after years of fighting through
appeals on august 24
2020 the california supreme court
reversed
peterson's death sentence for a possible
retrial
on the penalty while peterson's
convictions remain
intact supporters say they have proof
exonerating him all scott's activities
on december 24th are accounted for in a
case defined by
circumstantial evidence there are those
who still ask
what exactly happened to lacy
[Music]
let's start with the moment that sparked
everything the search the theories the
whole case
ron gransky's 9-1-1 phone call
my son-in-law called he was playing golf
morning 9 30. my daughter's been
listening to this morning she's eight
months pregnant she took her dog for a
walk in the heart
the dog came always just believed but
scott hadn't actually gone
golfing that day lacey's sister and
mother would testify that he told them
he was planning on playing golf when in
reality he went fishing
also when he went out from berkeley
marina he called his father and didn't
tell him he was out on the water in fact
his dad
didn't even didn't even know that scott
owned a boat so it raises questions if
he was lying about what he was up
to but scott never concealed the fact
that he went fishing
he was always consistent about that
whether he was talking to police or his
family
just said it was too cold for golf and
he switched plans all right maybe it was
a misunderstanding maybe it was
misinformation
the problem for scott peterson was that
the things he
said or didn't say and generally his
overall behavior
during the investigation wound up
hurting him for instance let's take a
look at when scott
sat down with detective albronkini from
modesto pd
the day after lacey went missing
you guys had any problems marriage
problems
everything's good you've been married
four years
four or five
so you're married in the 97 what
concerns me the most is the fact that
your dog came home with a leash
on that bothers me i mean
question yeah um what concerns me most
is doing
anything i can to further progress i
appreciate that
and i don't want you to hold i don't
want you to hold it against me i mean
sometimes i hate asking him so you got
to do it
but i do i really do have to do it aside
from him having trouble remembering when
he got married which is
you know not that great that kind of
nonchalant
casual almost aloof attitude when put
when his
wife is missing didn't really go over so
well with people and some
say that maybe he tried too hard to come
off as innocent
watch what happened when he sat down
with diane sawyer
i think everybody sitting at home wants
the answer to the same question did you
murder your wife
no no i just thought and
i had absolutely nothing to do with her
disappearance and
and use the word murder and yeah i mean
that is
a possibility um
it's not one we're ready to accept and
it creeps in my mind late at night
and early in the morning and during the
day
all we can think about is the right
resolution resolutions to find her
what kind of marriage was it
god i mean the first word that comes to
mind is you know glorious i mean we
took care of each other very well
um she was amazing
he was amazing so it's kind of weird
that you know because lacey hasn't been
found yet she hasn't been found dead
that it's weird that he uses the word
was
but listen i got a chance to sat down
with laura yaretzian
and she was on scott peterson's defense
team and i asked her all about this
you know what people behave in all sorts
of ways when they're
when they've just lost a someone close
to them there's no
right or wrong way of behaving and we
are very quick especially law
enforcement
very quick in judging people if he had
been crying a lot they would say oh look
he's putting on the show i've seen that
argument too
if you're too calm and you're in shock
oh see he doesn't care he's not crying i
believe
many of the jurors and everyone pretty
much in the public was preconditioned to
really
convict him i've always said it scott
was convicted before he stepped
foot in that courtroom for that trial
i'm joined now by long crime legal
analyst julie renderman and forensic
death investigator from jacksonville
state university joseph
scott morgan julie i want to start with
you i wonder if scott didn't speak to
police or the media and you just looked
only at the evidence
would we have seen a different result
for peterson
look you know one never knows what the
result would be we can only
guess i you know i say this and i've
said this to you a million times
if you are the person that has lost your
wife
and you are potentially the subject of
an investigation
let alone you're having an affair with
another woman
of which you're lying to that woman also
the best bet is to
keep your mouth shut because the problem
is the minute you
speak all that's going to happen is the
prosecutors are going to tear apart
every single word you say
every move you make every smile every
grimace
and they're going to use it to their
advantage there's nothing to be gained
and there was nothing to be gained
for him speaking to anyone uh in regards
to this investigation
and we can't forget that at the end of
the day though it seemed that
scott had an answer for everything for
example
he spoke to cbs 13 and he said that all
the injuries
on his hand they were from working on
farms
and machinery including on the day that
lacey vanished he claims
that he reached into a toolbox hit cut
himself
and that was maybe why it appeared that
there was blood
in the car although that hasn't been
positively identified now joseph let me
turn to you
other than the possibility of his wife's
hair
found on a pair of pliers how could
scott
have killed his wife and left no
physical evidence at the house
the warehouse the car or the boat
hey you know jesse one of the one of the
threads that's run through this whole
case over the years has been
what what methodology was employed in
order to end her life well it's very
simple it's
it's almost like the perfect murder
because a lot of people think that this
is a
smothering or a suffocation therefore
you're not going to have a bunch of
bloodletting if you will it won't be a
totally graphic scene where there's
blood spattered all over the place and
this sort of thing
there's not much to clean up so in
the grand scheme of things this was a
very simplistic methodology think about
think about just for a second we're
talking about a woman
who is eight and a half months pregnant
jesse she doesn't have
the ability to defend herself
and that's a really good point and
that's the thing that kind of straggles
people a little bit about this i mean
how
is it possible there's nothing there and
yet while that was
the prosecution's weakness in the end it
really didn't hurt them but there's a
lot we
do have to get to and i'll tell you what
when we come back
we're going to get into scott's alibi
the timeline
and i know what you're waiting for the
recordings with his mistress
amber fry we'll be back
would you be willing to take a polygraph
sure
so what you're telling me scott is
there's no
you have no idea where this is
scott peterson never did end up taking
that polygraph but he always maintained
that he
never murdered his wife lacey and their
unborn son
connor let's go back to his alibi for a
second because he says he went to a
warehouse
where he stored his boat he checked his
email he assembled the machine and then
he went out to the marina
now the evidence actually supports
that story but joseph going back to you
if this
is the timeline it seems that he would
have had to kill lacey
and then put her body in his truck while
he was working in the warehouse in broad
daylight for everyone to see
and that's a big criticism of the
prosecution's case does this make sense
to you
yeah it is it is very difficult for the
prosecution to overcome
i think probably what we're looking at
also jesse is the fact that
uh you know lexi's body was so
badly decomposed from a forensic
standpoint it's very difficult
for us to you know hang a definitive
timeline uh let's keep in mind
all of her internal organs were
essentially missing the only thing that
was intact was the uterus
we've also got the head and the limbs
that have been for lack of a better term
dismembered from the body uh even the
forensic pathologist could not make a
determination as to when some of this
trauma had occurred
so it leaves us out there kind of
hanging uh from a thread as we always
have been because there's nothing
definitive
that we can actually hang our hat on
right and look he goes out on his boat
for about what he says is an hour and a
half and you remember
the bodies of lacey and connor are
ultimately found near the area where he
claims he went fishing
and i want you to listen to what he says
he did the minute he came home
what did you do put my clothes in the
washer
check out those rags threw my clothes in
there
were you calling for lacey or oh yeah of
course
but she wasn't home no
assuming she's at her mom's
your you put your jeans your blue
t-shirt anything else in there
i think that green pullover was in there
too wasn't it yeah
did you did you use did you start the
washer
yeah did you put soap
okay then what uh grab some pizza from
the fridge
took the box out yeah put it on the
counter like it was
lots of milk
and jump in the shower joseph peters
peterson said it was normal for someone
who goes fishing to wash up nothing
crazy there but others said that
is incredibly suspicious your take
hey listen remember what we said earlier
relative to cause of death when we talk
about this idea of suffocation and
smothering there's no blood left behind
but let's keep this in mind uh she
lacy her body was missing the head and
the limbs
this is messy business okay now maybe he
didn't dismember her
but that would be a point
where uh you know this nastiness could
have occurred relative to
transfer of evidence onto clothing so
that has to be left out there to think
about
you know why would you purpose to wash
your clothes maybe it's just a neat guy
but again that question uh you know for
us has been asked but i don't know if
it's sufficiently been answered
and you just again look at his demeanor
throughout that says he's eating pizza
not a care in the world and that was
probably one of his biggest downfalls
but
one of the strongest pieces of evidence
for the state were the wiretap
phone calls between scott and his
mistress amber frye who
agreed to work with police and try to
catch scott on the phone
let's go back to new year's eve because
scott was at a candlelight vigil for
lacey
but guess where he told amber he was
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
he eventually comes clean about the
affair and says that he was lying about
being a widower
when he met her you deserve so much
better
there's no questions so much better yeah
and i deserve to understand
an explanation of why you told me you
lost your wife and this was the first
holidays you'd spend without her
that was december 9th you told me this
and now all sudden your wife's missing
[Applause]
of course you couldn't tell me the story
about your wife because it hadn't
happened yet
and you were hoping to resolve in
january that would be resolved and you'd
have a story to tell me
do you think i had something to do with
versus apparently
how are you feeling well let's see how
can i believe that
how can i believe that how could i
believe anything for
i am not evil like that
i would hope not i am oh my god are you
lying to me now
and he would even tell her that lacy
knew about the affair and was fine with
it
julie what role did amber play in
scott's gill
so amber i think we would describe as
the epicenter of this case she comes
forward i think a month
after lacey goes missing and she
basically
quite frankly makes this case explode
and we say that because she finally gave
investigators the motive
they needed for why scott peterson
would not want his wife in the picture
anymore and
everyone knows unfortunately when a
person goes missing and they're married
the first person you're going to look at
is the husband and you know they were
already looking at him i think amber
just
gave them you know gave such a frenzy
even to the media
that everyone became even more and more
focused um and the word she got from him
being able to establish that he not only
lied um to
everyone else he lied to her about what
was happening in regards to his
wife being alive or dead um to me goes
straight into an issue of motive
yep deception and motive those are the
two big things here now
scott peterson's death penalty may have
been overturned mostly because of
there were errors in jury selection but
his supporters say
that his conviction should be tossed out
too now scott's sister-in-law went on dr
phil
and she describes some of the evidence
that she says proves he's innocent
newly found evidence is that the mayo
man came down the street
between 10 35 and 10 50 the morning
of december 24th the mailman signed an
affidavit that said if mckenzie was in
the yard
or in the house he would bark at the
mailman
and on december 24 the mailman came by
and mckenzie was not on the property
basically what this means is that lacy
grabbed mckenzie and went on her walk
here's scott peterson's former attorney
on his future and
other suspects you know anything is
possible we've seen many cases
overturned
and it all depends on what the courts
decide
but i'm keeping hopeful and i'm staying
hopeful that it does happen
again i strongly believe just like many
other on the defense team and his family
that
scott didn't do this and he deserves
another trial
so that there was a burglary across the
street
on the day of her disappearance
and there was there was also some
conversation between an
inmate and his brother about accomplices
involved in that burglary and having
said that they saw lacy and lacy
basically tried to stop them so there
was talk obviously on the defense side
that
there's a great likelihood that they
actually took they're the ones who
kidnapped lazy because she caught him
red-handed
julia you're listening to this idea of
other evidence and i know prosecutors
have to decide if they want to retry
peterson on the death
penalty and the supreme court has said
that his convictions stand
as of now but could all of this change
one day could peterson ever go free
you know look i'm guessing no but could
he
yes i mean we have not only just the
issue regarding um the
you know the fact that the jurors um
were chosen basically
only those that agreed with the death
penalty which may have an impact
on their ability to be fair with regards
to the guilt or non-guilt of the
individual
i think the second issue that came out
also was the issue of publicity even
though they moved the case at least once
in that second jurisdiction there were
so many jurors that still believed he
was guilty even before they
heard all the evidence and then lastly
what we talk about right now in regards
to
other evidence it is true that if if the
defense is able to establish there's
other evidence that wasn't able to be
shown that would show that he is not
guilty
that may open the door to a possibility
of him getting a new trial
and julie real quick following up on
that about 30 seconds
you heard uh his sister-in-law mentioned
this idea of that there were people who
weren't interviewed that's a big deal
right
not necessarily um you know not every
single person has to be
interviewed in order for um
for there not to be a new trial the
question is if there's some someone that
wasn't interviewed that has real
evidence that will change the course of
this case
right and look here's what we do know
while the trial of scott peterson may
have ended
years ago the discussion has not and
with a possible new trial
this story is far from being over
well that's all we have for you tonight
on prime crime tonight
tell you what you should give us your
comments on scott peterson or in any of
the other cases we've covered you can go
on twitter and facebook
with the hashtag primecrimetonight thank
you
for joining us and until next time be
safe
[Music]
you